all right so what does he have there it
is ha ha ha nice you got it bye that's
just what I wanted to happen
what's up gamers magic time please look
like a baby the video place behaves but
hey hey if you don't know anything about
card games or magic all you need to know
no you need to know a lot of things how
do I treat this video I don't know
everyone plays the same King deck okay
there's a limited a bunch of cards and
people have figured out okay this is the
best combination of cards so everyone
just plays the same goddamn decks all
over again you can play a deck that
everyone else plays or you could play
something that is good against these
decks an answer to that is angry white
woman we had hunted witness very good
day against mana read a two-for-one
trade of legions landing good form on
the red titty shaker good against mana
blue die your fleet daredevil I love
this card so much very underutilized
card
hopefully we get to see some action of
it maybe you shouldn't have lava coil
big lava coil just good removal just
strike it's nice to have an instant
removal resplendent angel and breakable
formation I only have a breakable
formation for expert control Legion war
boss because it helps flipping the
legions landing and again if you have
unbreakable formation with it it's very
nice excellent finding self-explanatory
rekindling Felix because Felix really
because why not
Aurelia it's my favorite card of the
deck it's so good and then of course
Lyra three Liars because you
I literally just hit mythic rank again
third time baby feels good man
my name is now PewDiePie forever number
one because someone reported my name
thanks for that appreciate that
it used to be asked like her 47 and then
someone reported my name and then that
just led to me asking to change it I
changed it into a bunch of joke name so
I added like fortnight game or 47 or
like played against
musashi you don't see green a lot these
days I pick for that gamer or like smoke
bush for 19 plus one and then they just
basically dabbed on me and said I don't
have any removal I'm basically screwed
here titty shaker go
apparently I have the attention span of
a five-year-old they changed my name to
sub T series that's it that was the
point of the story yeah this game is
lost I don't know what to tell you guys
there you go it begins the pain begins
I'd literally used to run for two
counties just against these kind of
decks but I never see them anymore so I
just removed them but I guess here we go
holy how much thinking do you need
to make you did it congratulations
now give me a lava coil alright
this game is over I don't know what to
tell you guys I could flip the legions
but that would cost me two creatures but
also what do I have to lose at this
point then then if we draw a line right
now that's the only way I really see
this oh you figured out which one to
block with Congrats you idiot you fool I
had hunted witness all along please no
mana okay there's no mana great
he literally has no mana that's amazing
hey look at that
okay so now he wants to play his disc
our next turn so I don't think he'll
take the block and that means we can
what am i doing what am i doing
I did not expect that okay
you place the Rangers right he gets
lives and cards and good times and I get
to suck dick if we draw Mountain extern
we're in pretty good shape
let's just keep attacking with our air
support keep the pressure on this
it's not as long as it doesn't play any
good cards I think we're okay oh I just
noticed 1069 he has a lot of cards
that's a lot of cards play the lion
maybe this pro tip you can you can play
that Lane I don't know if you knew about
this but you can play lions did he hold
her to play a Landis turn I didn't pay
attention so he has four mana maybe he's
contemplating playing the crack the
snake flyer because that's usually what
all right you played the lion you
did it you didn't pay the life for it
though so that means he's not playing to
snake this turn taking a long time here
buddy
taking a very long time by the gods
you're taking a very long time I don't
know if you knew about this but you
taking a Barrett he did it got sad isn't
it alright I wish he had gone for my
angel
but I guess air support go oh you
believe in land again
no no get away get away oh yeah no
maybe your oh he played another
elf that cheeky
ah I need another line it would be so
good if I got a lot of line all right
you go there you go there and you guys
just sit tie it all right I okay well I
should have played Legion more bus and
landing that I prefer our support right
now if we can draw a line next turn then
it's pretty much over because then I can
activate the ability we get to token
angels and well it's over regardless I
have lethal next turn but yeah it's a
clamp his ass cheeks though I don't
think so
that's strange I guess he wanted to
double play I would have gone for more
buff on the snake I guess he wants life
he knows there you go no I'm missing oh
it's a red land it's a red land oh that
sucks it really sucks ooh ooh I wonder
if this works no way it doesn't I
thought if I can activate this then
flick the landing and then get another
white mana but I need this to activate
this turn
okay we're just gonna god damn that
sucks could I could I have done that
I'll try next turn I'll try next turn if
I can but now the game is stalled so I
don't think this is Gigi anymore red
mana can't believe it or red mana pure
ready I think I only have like ah God it
begins the pain you're just pulling the
best cards you could possibly pull
aren't you I don't like this I don't
like this game anymore this does not
look good for me at all
that look okay alright give me the white
mana so I know I can activate this
ability during combat and kind of trick
him to kill the snake but I don't trust
this game a lot of the times
he could choose to kill my flier but I'd
rather make sure that baby and dives in
case he just decided to block my
resplendent angel you know what I mean
you know what I mean
I like where they always look at the
bottom ones like they're flying oh
he did do that okay interesting so
unless you can pull another Vivian out
of your ass it's not looking too good
for you another Vivian or a snake that's
all I don't want to see you can do
whatever you want in between there or
finality okay there's a lot of cards
that he could pull out of his ass
that one I'm fine with go ahead go ahead
I don't care yeah yeah yeah get go yeah
you guys you got a bunch of lanes but
you ain't got no snakes what I call it a
snake it looks like a snake oh now I can
activate the ability oh well doesn't
matter who do we mentor the life link we
don't have lethal we're one against
lethal he has to block with the snake
well he doesn't have to he'd be wise to
block with a snake oh you blocked that
one with the snake why all right so he's
down to one health next turn and we
don't have to buff it cuz the life link
of this will give us the triggered
ability anyway shut okay I got nothing
oh you doctor one now and now you
should met shouldn't that trigger why
did it not trigger oh that one didn't
have life link okay I'm an idiot bye
doesn't matter doesn't matter that I
miscalculated and did a couple of
misplace because I'm the best gamer of
the world you guys don't understand
don't even try to have your pre built
shitty decks going Oh guru's pretty good
pathetic the epic I can't play anything
turn one that's always fun oh my
god this again alright take this
moustache man go paranoid moustache man
that would kill him not God Jesus Christ
the synergy begins a talk yeah cool I
have no removal this is epic do I block
that I feel like I need to save it for a
later block health collectors is gonna
get stronger now I can't play
resplendent I can't play anything I'm
basically I don't want to play dire
fleet daredevil but I also don't think
this guy plays any spells
usually these kind of decks don't so
we'll see he shocks himself to play
another I hope he doesn't get buffed it
does cool that means Pelt protector gets
buffed as well that's awesome
or does it it doesn't okay nevermind
then I don't know how they works I never
play with it um tricky tricky tricky hmm
how many does he have a graveyard one so
if he plays a crowd 3 it will be 4 or so
you won't die so I can play this now and
I can buff this guy and most likely they
won't take the block they might either
way I get life back which I gladly take
I probably should have tried to flip the
Legion they're actually open another
creature died he gets buff that's how it
works how do I not know that that's
really good whenever a creature you
control and divide it or dies if that
creatures power is greater oh I see okay
you know these things
alright is he gonna play this guy yeah
alright so what do I want to do here I
feel like I want to flip the Legion but
it doesn't seem worth it right now
oh really I can put pressure for now dye
fleet daredevil will hold off anymore
fault
this is have trample no it isn't okay
[Music]
will he attack this turn he does nine oh
one two three four five
well how much money don't have I have
six alright GG boys bye
good game it's over mr. Devine you can
gg
it's over please I actually don't know
if it's over I don't know what he has
well he does oh he goes for the attack
that's cute I mean what what are you
gonna do alright there's a dog trampled
No
should I let that one slide what could
he have he could have moment of craving
doesn't matter he's that anyway
nice good move that was really good no
he tricked back he doesn't know I have
explained it angel it's fine what
else do you got yeah yes keep staring at
it see what happens
oh you thought you could trick the trick
sir I didn't trick him at all he tricked
me but I just had a second car that
could win oh why I love magic
so fun he thought he had me that's
hilarious
I was acting cocky too even though I
know he could have had something against
me but thank God I that could have been
really humiliating for sure I don't love
this hand I could potentially have three
dead cards but what are you gonna do
69 epic what do I play I'll pay it could
be mana red I would suck it but so far I
haven't seen it in mythic how great is
s4 gg
like I said three dead cards sorry let's
attack for one and then he 19 rounds
he's dead
seems like a solid plan to me how can
you still play it oh he's not Esper what
then what are you
titty shaker he plays titty shaker what
alright I'll go for a taxi betrayed
doubted nope but I have another paranoid
mustache man yeah
squeeze one damage out of here I don't
like when they are God it begins yeah I
thought every sure so what would I take
if I was him I don't know what cards he
adds probably exelon yeah
Oh God the thing I hate about thought
race is that they get to survey
afterwards so not only do you have to
wait for them to decide which card to
pick the olds have to decide what car to
pick in they're an I don't like
it okay
let's attack what are you gonna do with
mr. titty shaker a lot of thought
process going into this decision to
damage that is a considerable amount he
managed to make a decision
absolutely incredible okay if
resplendent angel doesn't die this turn
I think we might be in a good shape but
I also see a removal coming probably
cast down or a jihad nany all right I
Johnny what is this deck all right
you're gonna buff the titty shaker come
on Jesus Christ just do it you did it
congratulations I think I'll just say
he'll go to six I need two turns to kill
him yeah I think the best way does a
whole lot for now he will he will buff
titty shaker next turn so I can't block
him with a hundred witness so
technically I should probably keep
attacking right now
but regardless Johnny will be dead next
time I don't feel like wasting tokens
lash out
Oh dah so does have any I'm more
creepers
then also potentially forget an
allegiance landing a car
what is this deck I see what he draws
then I'm legit curious now we get to see
some stuff at least what exile target
creature put two loyal encounters on a
Plains Walker
it's a planeswalker deck exile target
creature I don't like that don't examine
my creatures
well now it's like now I have to kill
car all right we'll see if we draw he
doesn't attack he's a boy
interesting ok so we can't play your IRA
this turn but we can next one
unbreakable formation won't do anything
against exile do we want to use them
right it's too late to use it now ok no
what am i doing I was supposed oh
you dumbass alright I can
I can save this it was a plan - it was a
plan to play justice strike next turned
out that was the plan sure let's go with
that
alright so now he'll - Karn no he
doesn't ok you get a lion
it's oh it's if the French it's a friend
stick so the titty shaker is just a
distraction it's literally just to keep
something on the board I like this kind
of decks but if he goes on too long
we're gonna be in trouble
deal combat damage well that's not gonna
happen
are you are you gonna deal combat damage
alright
so it's a bit to play this on
his turn but oh god I'm actually
now we can actually
brain-dead let's go for con the Miss
plays I'm making is just freaking
pathetic why why would you not block her
splendid angel why why weird alright so
he goes for the exile card he'll
probably use it on Lyra but we have
another lion he doesn't know about that
so it doesn't really matter he actually
just saves us some time well that might
be annoying is it that fast
that sucks we might just have to go for
his face yeah we might just have to go
for his face I'll kill that all right so
now the goal is to ignore Jace and just
go for its face that rhymed as well
doesn't make me so anxious to play
against I don't know what's happening I
mean it has a bored wife I'm pretty much
screwed we lost our only protection for
it you never see people playing Jays
it's really interesting it's not a good
card maybe if you have oath of Teferi
you can make it work I'm surprised you
managed to get it too it's just too many
Planeswalkers pong play tribunal by Lara
it's okay we can still activate
resplendent Angels ability so it doesn't
really matter he doesn't have any flight
control
yeah all right oh I think I'll save it
just because if there's a bored wife I'm
screwed basically so we have lethal next
turn anyway so unless you have a bored
white I think it's sayonara I miss
service cilona considering how long he's
thinking about it I don't think he has
support why all right going into the
thinking phase thinking hard oh no not
more not more tokens on the ground what
will I ever do I guess his tactic is
really just to get these out as
protection and not roll like if I had a
deck like this I would run settle to the
wreckage or he attacks or something like
that you know
so no combat damage has been done he
hasn't spent any money yet and I just
barley fell because I blocked the titty
shaker cuz I'm actually a freaking brain
light I was a good move
I'm an idiot I forgot about the plier
that was a pretty bad miss play on me I
gotta say there was really no reason for
me to block the titty shaker I just saw
it I don't want him to draw another card
that's a lot of clicking to do yeah it's
kind of cool I never see people play
this I played it in one neck
alright I don't have a no I have a
choice I can block all of these I'd
rather keep him from drawing cards
tonight the malleus it's good game
yeah I don't really feel good about that
one I'm not gonna lie that was pretty
tame three in a row baby
let's make four angry white women you
don't understand the power it's really
not that good of a dick I hope people
don't watch Mona blue potentially have
not played that in a while
it's definitely mana blue considering
that hey he opted everyone Wow
oh he went for top I don't like that I
do not like that no it's not mana blue
coil
why would you waste a lava coil on a in
hunted witness that's really good that
he played that because we have dire
fleet daredevil I will not play that
then any extra lava coils again Drake is
as amazing he basically gave us one
obviously he doesn't know that so Drake
or Phoenix's you just have to keep
paying attention to their graveyard to
see if the Phoenix is in there it isn't
so far the longer that goes the better
again no reason to play anything until
turn four
depending on what he plays now okay
perfect it's tempting for me to just
play exons binding as a Bigfoot you he's
tapped out as well and yeah why not hey
usually red-blue doesn't have any
enchantment removal see there it is
there's the Phoenix he hard casted it
and here's me laughing my ass off
because your Phoenix has gone forever
sayonara Phoenix Sun maybe you shouldn't
have lava coil why is he not
clicking oh god why is it oh thank god
oh no oh well he doesn't look too good
for you does he why don't you play
another Drake huh Hitler miss a does he
discard does it discard another one
please don't please no it didn't it
discovered a new lion another one
he's digging deep no no Phoenix's oh
[Music]
another one in hell dude three in a row
and never bothered it's okay he got it
that was nice I'll give him that
we can't actually play our Phoenix
that's a little annoying let's go for
some life gain I would say we might as
well play bow and another legions
landing so hopefully we can flip it next
turn doesn't matter that much at this
point alright it looks like it's going
for another Phoenix or you just want to
get better cards alright that's two and
that's three yeah I guess he's just
digging at this point
I have a feeling he probably just has a
shock or something like that so I'm
better off not blocking he could
obviously get a Phoenix out now it's
very likely interesting oh that's
interesting
should I play that now or later I can't
play the Phoenix and I think I need to
start dominating a little bit so now the
dire fleet tower devil can deal with any
Phoenix's if he decides to block we
should still buff the daredevil I think
I'm not sure if that's the best move but
we're hitting them pretty hard here
damn he didn't even block with anything
he must okay that makes me a little
worried actually we'll see what happens
radical idea on my end step interesting
he must be digging alright
the digging commences he can play a lot
of cards here it makes me worried he's
gone through half the deck to phoenixes
there's two more come on this is so
anxious come on he's looking a lot of
the cards or she there is actually
female magic players all four of them
all right
it doesn't discard a Phoenix keep it
that way I like that I like that a lot
he has a lot of cards he could keep
playing come on Oh he passes two
attackers
so no Phoenix's what does that mean we
win no he's not done
now he does that okay surveil to than
drawcard why would he do that after
attacking he could have gone into
Phoenix what was that a mistake
ah that sucks that really sucks we still
live lethal ah sucks
ah and here's the shock alright you
don't have lethal
we lost lethal I repeat we lost but
where's my red mana dude alright I think
just keeping the pressure on now that
he's so low health and we have legions
landing is really the way to go but the
fact that this brings him down to one is
nerve-wracking to say the least
oh that's that Drake you couldn't play
so sad for you alright
so let's play this and pray to the gods
that that's not a draw card spell yeah
Oh angry and damn foreigner oh baby bar
in a row
am i playing against myself it's Mona
why we should be okay against this I
don't really see this I don't know why
you would play this type of deck in
mythic not to just I think I don't want
to play Legion actually so I think he's
gonna play at Johnny and I just want to
kill a Johnny right away he doesn't play
a Johnny I just waste at a time
it's actually not that bad because now
he's tapped out and we can play leaving
more box and he's not gonna he's not
gonna take that straight and the more we
can build up the Legion the batter why
it doesn't right
run more boardwax he does have removal
though
so far yeah it looks bad but I'm really
not worried so we can play titty shaker
and legions landing and then we're going
Lyra next turn so the more he can waste
his removal is the better we wanted time
we want to flip our legion so next turn
I'll just walk with titty shaker
hopefully he waste his removals he does
fine okay I'm not blocking anything this
time Oh does that exile oh I didn't know
it exile
then I will block this turn except I
came all right let's get rid of this
it's annoying
I'll save x1 in case he has sac on clay
tribunal but home to I'm sorry I mean
why are you playing this garbage tank
like why what are you hoping to achieve
oh you're not doing anything now that's
cute
go Lyra go why don't you block with your
little birds that BQ I love Lara so much
as soon as she enters the board it's
like the whole game has changed
completely all right let's play this and
this and this and see what they play we
can justice strike whatever they got
anyway easy oh not the bodyguard six
hours too late what the hell is the
worst why dagger I've seen I guess he
was waiting for a Johnny I get it but
it's like I have removals for it
I want him I hope he's hoping to get it
so that once he finally gets it out I
can just go hey he does get or health
back each turn though I'll give him that
like this is kind of annoying we're both
a life gaming back at this point the
thing is we are gaining way more health
than they are so my god this is so long
another bodyguard
I guess he's waiting for like a legion
whatever they call
Michael this is so boring welcome to
magic everyone thank you thank you all
right now we can apply some French here
now the game dynamic change for you
didn't a lyra has vigilance and dust for
seven cool you managed to stay alive now
what why don't you attack me I want it I
want him to get a good car just so I can
destroy his confidence his emotions I
should have flipped the légion there but
it's not that important right now
never know the creature enters okay you
want to play any more useless cards or
are you done with that okay he doesn't
attack that's cute
do we buff Lyra or a really yeah like we
should Aurelia and then try and flip the
landing my name trying as 100%
completing because then he can him
and then he's forced to sack one of its
creatures you want to block alright I
will just concede good game
he doesn't give up I mean he's still in
there
he's got more than half his hell oh
that's annoying
that's actually really good I might have
to binding that he's going all out boys
he's going all out so I don't want him
to I'll kill the ones that give him life
what am i doing there you go okay
there it is
hahaha nice you got it bye that's just
what I wanted to happen I'm so thankful
so there you have it everyone angry
white Vaman it's a pretty versatile deck
dire fleet daredevil I gotta say I love
this card I really should have more of
it but a lot of these just go on the
principle of two for one so this is two
for one
this could be a 2 for 1 this is 2 for 1
this is 2 for 1 it buffs itself this is
2 for 1
this is almost always 2 for 1 this is so
strong so he's almost always two for one
two for one so it's really good against
aggro it's just too slow for us for
control it always loses almost always
unless I have been breakable well yeah
that's it hope you guys enjoyed this
video
I know not everyone likes magic but it's
just one of those days so cry me a river